thank you but before and it's my job
again to very very briefly give an
introduction to Laurie who is then going
to be introducing our first keynote
address before that though I just wanted
to reiterate and what Anna said and
personally thank Anna also for all her
work this has been you know a gigantic
effort to get all this together and I
also want to recognize Debbie Stein and
Joe he's ur who also are associate
directors at the Scott Institute and
their work is scattered throughout and
especially on Friday Debbie Big Show is
the allegheny clean tech competition
which were extremely excited about
innovation is in the title of the Scott
Institute and this is a showcase for
innovation both regionally and within
the university and so it's a again my
distinct pleasure to not have to have
done most of what you're seeing here so
I'm just it's great to show up and be
part of this but a lot of credit goes to
the staff of the Scott Institute who are
to a person incredibly competent and
great people
so one last thanks to them and then
we'll
so Laurie uh weingartz is the moderator
of this coming panel she's responsible
for leading the she's the interim
provost for CMU and she's responsible
for leading all the schools colleges and
Institute's and academic planning
implementation also she's a nationally
and internationally recognized scholar
on group processes and social motives
and tactical behavior that effect
negotiation later this evening she'll
also be the moderator for the
distinguished mayor's forum with Mayor
Carmen Cruz from Puerto Rico and Mayor
Bill Peduto from Pittsburgh and will be
fantastic to see how about all that goes
and so I hope that you stick around for
not only this session right now but come
back tonight to hear that amazing
interaction so without further ado
Laurie good morning everyone welcome to
today's energy Week keynote at Carnegie
Mellon we're featuring our very special
guest and prema Jory we're very happy
you could join us for this third annual
CMU energy week as you know it's
organized by Carnegie Mellon's Wilton
East Scott Institute this energy week
2018 brings to campus thought leaders as
you know from industry government
academia the nonprofit sector to engage
and collaborate on energy research
trends innovative technologies and
opportunities now I'd like to share a
little bit with you about our very
special speaker today and Primeau Jory
is one of the nation's top corporate
executives in energy and utilities and a
sterling example of what women can
achieve in corporate leadership as
president and CEO of ComEd one of the
most influential electric utilities in
the state of Illinois and oversees a
delivery of electricity to 3.8 million
customers in Chicago and northern
Illinois and as a native Chicagoan
myself I'm especially interested to hear
what she has to say the next time the
power goes out for my family back home
I'll know who to call okay seriously I'm
Ann join ComEd is the lead lawyer and
had a regulatory policy
in the late-1990s working on the
company's transition to competitive
energy markets she rose to become CEO in
2009 overseeing the day-to-day
operations of the electric grid and
customer operations in 2012
ComEd made her the first woman to hold
the post of president and CEO under her
leadership earlier this year
ComEd became one of the first utilities
in the nation approved to build a micro
grid cluster with that kind of impact
it's no wonder that she serves on the
board of directors for the Chicago
Federal Reserve Motorola Solutions
Babcock & Wilcox enterprises and several
civic and community organizations
notably and took a very non-traditional
path to corporate energy success
she studied communications in theater at
the at Miami University of Ohio before
earning a law degree at DePaul
University and transitioning into the
energy sector it does make me wonder if
she has a little Carnegie Mellon DNA in
her now as we say that's so CMU and is a
perfect example of what we are about
here at Carnegie Mellon
cross-disciplinary research and
education that produces outstanding and
innovative results and we're very
pleased to have you with us here to
address us today so please join me in
welcoming and Parma jury
[Applause]
all right Thank You Lori that was a
great introduction I appreciate it and
you can call me or your family and call
me with an outage any time we we learn
to live with that as as utility
executives were pretty much 24/7 and we
take all phone calls interestingly
recently a phone call that we took was
from Puerto Rico and I you know you're
having the the mayor of San Juan here
and I think that's very exciting we
actually have crews down in Puerto Rico
now we've been down there for several
months doing work and I can say that's
been some of the most impactful work
that I think our company has done to be
able to go down there and provide relief
to those people who have been without
power for months and months and months
so a great experience and I just share
that on the note of collaboration and
the way our industry works together
David Owen is here and part of a EEI the
association of utilities investor owned
utilities across the country and this is
what we do when there's a big event a
big disaster we come together and and
support each other and so I thought I'd
mention that but I will also talk a lot
about collaboration and working together
and how we get this energy
transformation done but I'm delighted to
be here at Carnegie Mellon and in the
city of Pittsburgh both the institution
in the city are renowned for invention
and perhaps more importantly for their
partnership in the city's reinvention
invention is hard reinvention is harder
invention takes intelligence vision and
Drive reinvention takes all that and
more with reinvention you don't have the
luxury of starting from a blank
whiteboard you're required to build on
top of and around infrastructure that
already exists you're required to
address economic interests and
renegotiate social expectations
long and deeply embedded in an existing
system it's making sure that you don't
tug on the thread that unravels the
existing system before you've built the
new one so Pittsburgh figured out this
delicate weave Pittsburgh created a
viable vision for the future based on a
clear understanding of its past
in fact it reformed its original
construction as Steel City and built a
new economy leveraging its past
industrial leadership from smoky city to
robobird a technology-based city poised
for the future and that evolution made a
lot of sense because it stayed true to
the area's core strengths as one
observer put it Pittsburgh is a place
where stuff gets made in building its
new economy Pittsburgh defined a mission
to create a sustainable engaging city
with a commitment to 100% renewable
energy and Pittsburgh had resources in
addition to its technical past it had a
group of civic governmental academic and
business partners who came together
because they recognized that the mission
couldn't be achieved unless all
interests connected this reinvention
didn't happen by chance like every good
revolution it had a vision a mission the
technology and resources to execute on
the vision and a recognition by
stakeholders with no local knowledge and
a systems perspective that every piece
you touch physical economic social is
interconnected to every other piece in a
delicately balanced weave the recipe
worked the region has seen its
population grow by 40 percent
since 2000 the innovation economy with
Carnegie Mellon at the epicenter is
booming the quality of life is saturated
with culture and low cost living and the
city has become a destination a few
years ago the president of Pittsburgh's
Downtown Partnership provided a great
validation of the city's rebound he said
in the city we are starting to see
strollers
so in energy we are also in the midst of
reinvention frankly I prefer calling it
a revolution it's personal to me I was a
kid in the 1960s and found all the talk
of social change and revolution
intoxicating by the time I had really
grown up and could be active in anything
I found myself in the 1980s out of denim
bell-bottoms and wearing white polyester
pants we somehow had moved from civil
rights and spiritual enlightenment at
Woodstock to dirty dancing at Saturday
Night Live discos from Jimi Hendrix and
Janis Joplin to Wham and the biggest
fraud perpetrated in pop music Milli
Vanilli I have never gotten over it so
I'm claiming my revolution here right
now in the transformation of the energy
sector and you all know it's a
revolution you see it you feel it you're
part of it it's the second electric
revolution being designed to support the
developed world's third Industrial
Revolution and the revolution has all
the ingredients of Pittsburgh's
reinvention there's a vision which is to
build an energy system of six attributes
clean or lean or smarter more reliable
more resilient and more custom there's a
mission to create a system to serve a
digital economy and to make the benefits
broadly accessible to all people there
is increasingly the tools and technology
to make it happen and there can be no
question that redesigning the most
complex Network machine in the world and
unraveling an economic structure
embedded in laws developed over a
hundred years requires an alliance of
stakeholders all of whom understand that
every piece we touch is interconnected
so I want to spend my minutes with you
today talking about what the road map
for this revolution should look like and
how we're executing on the road map at
comment but before we talk about where
we're going it's important to talk about
where we came from and Pittsburgh
understood this just like Pittsburgh
we're not writing on a blank white board
we're constructing on top of existing in
structure physical economic and social I
come from Chicago and its utility
Commonwealth Edison and I'm not writing
on a blank whiteboard either in fact at
the turn of the last century Chicago and
Commonwealth Edison were the epicenter
of the emerging electric industry
Chicago is where Thomas Edison sent his
top lieutenants Sam in Seoul to find a
way to sell his light bulbs on a massive
scale
but in Seoul did far more than that he
made my hometown the birthplace of the
industry's business and operating model
he invented a whole new approach to
generate distribute and finance electric
power in Seoul centralized power
generation and distribution rolling up
decentralized power providers and
systems into one entity that could
produce electricity at mass scale as
Edison said of building the early grid
it was necessary to invent everything
dynamos regulators meter switches fuses
fixtures and a host of other parts in
Seoul whoa of all these parts together
with investments in the physical grid
tied to a complete set of economic and
regulatory layers all creating a social
compact full of expectations for what
became an essential service to our
economy and quality of life
eventually in seoul's model overwhelmed
and overhauled this industry in 2000 the
US National Academy of Engineering
declared the creation of a national
electric grid the greatest engineering
achievement of the twentieth century it
was the greatest because it made most
every other innovation possible either
because electricity is used to make it
or electricity is needed to run it the
edison insole model is remarkable for
its massive impact on the physical
economic and social aspects of 20 20th
century American life but ironically in
Seoul's model is most notable because it
sowed the seeds of its own demise the
20th century relic is the gateway to the
20th first century economy today our
electric system has enabled the
emergence of the third Industrial
Revolution where everything is digital
billions of people and countless device
can communicate across borders and
oceans where mobile computing is how we
live automation is part of our economic
DNA and artificial intelligence is no
longer a futuristic dream and in this
world it seems everything is electric
from the ubiquitous ecommerce technology
that undergirds our economy to the
robots of Pittsburgh to the tools of the
healthcare system to the future of
transportation and perhaps in its most
unexpected twist the new economic
revolution the model in this enabled is
calling for an energy system that is
more distributed more competitive more
akin to the one in Seoul redesigned a
hundred years ago we are going back to
the future
so the first electric revolution sowed
the seeds for what we now know is the
digital electric world
but the fertilizer for its growth
emerged in 1962 yeah 1962 why 1962 I
don't know how do I know that it was in
1962 I don't even know why I came across
this but 1962 was the year with the
publication of Rachel Carson's Silent
Spring launching the environmental
movement and creating a mission for our
future system in 1962 we saw the
invention of the light emitting diode
initiating energy efficiency technology
reflecting an industry shift in
perspective around enabling technology
and the introduction by a group of
prescient animators of a futuristic
family illuminating an electric world
and providing a vision for the future
had I known I could have helped Thank
You 21st century transportation space
robotics teleconferencing and schools
[Applause]
1962 the Jetsons of the Jetsons world is
no fantasy the mission of sustainability
will not be denied and the technology
tsunami started by LEDs is only gaining
force this future world is no fraud it
is no Milli Vanilli it is here and it
comed we take quite seriously this
vision of a future electric world not
surprisingly we believed as did
pittsburgh that not only can this new
world be built on the existing system we
believe the existing system makes the
new electric world possible no one
disputes the energy system of the 21st
century must look very different from
its predecessor but some suggest that
the grid itself is obsolete imagining a
totally disconnected and distributed
system to this course of the
disconnected I'd simply paraphrase Mark
Twain reports of the grids death are
greatly exaggerated in a world where
every household can be its own personal
power plant where there are more
electric vehicles on the road where
power is coming from into many different
places the grid becomes more important
not less and the reason is simple it's
the power of networks
according to UC Berkeley professor carl
shapiro there is a central difference
between the old and new economies the
old industrial economy was driven by
economies of scale the new information
economy is driven by the economy of
networks the internet and wireless
networks are of course the most visible
symbols of our economic era but at its
most basic level the electric grid is
just one big network to
connecting people homes businesses
schools hospitals and virtually anyone
or anything that requires power which in
our modern economy means basically
everyone and everything
put another way a single home with its
own rooftop solar array and a basement
battery is a powerful idea but becomes
far more powerful if that setup is part
of a network that does what networks do
enhance choice generate efficiencies and
create opportunity so it comed we're
approaching the future in a way that
both honors the past successes of the
electric grid and allows for new uses
customers will make of it
we're designing a platform that enables
us to offer the strength and stability
of the interconnected network and the
innovation and choice that independent
markets so effectively offer like
Pittsburgh's reinvention roadmap were
focused on the physical economic and
social threads of our reinvention our
first area of focus is building a
physical infrastructure that
incorporates the sixths attributes I
mentioned earlier clean lean smart
reliable resilient and custom and the
service imperative of broad
accessibility in Illinois we've just
completed a six year modernization
program adding smart meters Smart
Switches smart sensors smart substations
all of which have combined to improve
reliability by 50% and cut save our
customers billions of dollars check
reliability we recognize that 20th
century reliability as a 21st century
cousin resilience driven by the need to
withstand challenges of a changing
climate and security environment comment
is addressing this requirement with more
underground infrastructure more
modularity in design and through new
experimental technology like
superconducting cable which will allow
us to connect multiple substations in
the Chicago business district and lean
on the excess capacity in one substation
in a way not currently possible in the
event another substation experiences a
problem
check resiliency we address lean through
our five-year voltage optimization
program through which will fit half of
our five thousand feeders with
technology that allows us to control
voltage more tightly and reduce
system-wide energy usage in the range we
expect about 2% check lean and our solar
for all programs set out in Illinois
future energy Jobs Act creates a path
for 3,000 megawatts of solar
predominantly community scale moving
toward clean and assuring the broadest
access possible and on the attribute of
custom we're working on pricing and
services tailored toward individuals or
individual customers but our initial
foray is focused on information with
pilots like personal reliability reports
and data services like this
[Music]
[Applause]
pretty vacuum yesterday there was a
there was a power outage I could vacuum
like that yes comment when was our last
outage your last outage was over a year
ago would you like me to give you the
details
[Music]
thank you check custom those are
actually our employees and Laurie next
time your folks need information on
their outages we're sending them to a
lexer echo we don't do rockets that
would not be mine so that's the work on
the physical network we also have work
to do to upgrade the economic system and
until very recently the focus of our
business had been on pushing power
through a linear pipeline of mass
production and distribution all
controlled by a single entity the
vertically integrated pipeline business
however is a relic of the 20th century
that's not how the economy functions
anymore not in the era of the smartphone
in the internet the age of eBay Facebook
uber Airbnb and more each of them
platforms networks that provide the
architecture for people to interact move
rent buy sell and work simply put
platforms are the dominant business
model of our time and if you're an
existing company and you want to survive
you can't keep singing the same old tune
you have to compose a whole new score
but the electric industry a networked
industry is well suited to a platform
economic model and if we get the digital
melodies and technological harmonies
down right our evolving electric grid
has the potential to become one of the
most important platforms in the economy
so we're exploring accomplishing this
through a four layer model that begins
with the infrastructure of today the
physical system and builds an operating
and planning function one layer up still
very much traditional utility layer
three is focused on energy transactions
starting to get away from traditional
utility topped off by a fourth layer
featuring services like energy
efficiency demand management and solar
services utilities will need to fulfill
the same core responsibilities
delivering affordable reliable power
when and where its
needed but now we're inviting a
multitude of actors sellers and buyers
of energy services and information to
interact on the grid as well it blends
the stability of the old world with the
choice and agility of the digital age
now our engineers love adding new
technology to the grid and working
through fascinating economic models like
the platform fuels the enthusiasm of are
very smart economists and financial
minds but as it was in Pittsburgh
reinvention the system must at the end
of the day work for people so we're hard
at work exploring the social
implications of all this change in
parallel with the physical and economic
questions in designing the energy system
of the future there will no be no
one-size-fits-all solution like we've
had in the past the technology economics
and consumer expectations are driving to
smaller solutions within the larger
Network like community generation and
micro grids on Chicago's South Side in
the Bronzeville neighborhood we're
beginning to build a community micro
grid we're designing what may be the
nation's first small network of micro
grids as we connect the ComEd micro grid
to an existing micro grid at Illinois
Tech or the Illinois Institute of
Technology as it was formerly known and
integrate control technology that will
allow for dispatch across the two micro
grids and sharing and optimizing
resources in the event of outages these
micro grids play a unique technical role
in developing grid resilience but we'll
also explore the power of people
community and connection our Bronzeville
project will allow us to experiment with
the social aspect of electric
infrastructure as never before we will
be testing the concept of an electric
ecosystem of technology driven services
to support a community by adding
concepts like smart streetlights
demonstrating electric vehicle
ride-sharing as a community mobility
solution installing wind solar and
battery powered outdoor lighting units
to create safer spaces
and establishing community information
kiosks but perhaps the most important
test is the connection we make with
customers and the connection community
members can make to one another so we
will also be testing community
connection concepts through a sharing
economy program where we will afford
customers participating in our energy
efficiency programs the ability to use
their savings to reduce their bill as
they do today or to donate the savings
to a school or church or a community
organization and the social crown jewel
is the experimental trading platform we
have in the design phase to incent
energy efficiency investment we are
developing an attribute a tradable
attribute around a kilowatt hour
reduction we hope to design a trading
platform via smart contracts now I'm not
an engineer by training but am a geek at
heart so I get really excited about the
technical aspects of micro grids but
here's why I think they're truly special
they meet us where we are they're a
solution for how more and more of us
live in 2017 and 2018 the most exciting
innovations are often happening at the
neighborhood level and micro grids allow
us to meet the unique needs of each
neighborhood and draw on the unique
strengths of local communities while
taking advantage of the overall
interconnectedness of the grid so I've
thrown a lot at you this morning
reinvention roadmaps platform models
Network economics micro grids milli
vanilli so what's the take away even as
utilities helped lead the effort to
reinvent our energy system we must do so
under much tougher conditions than many
other innovators we can't simply focus
on the exciting technical aspects alone
or any other single aspects of
transformation without minding the broad
system effects some of you may be
familiar with a book that came out a
year or so ago that aptly describes how
Silicon Valley approaches innovation
it's called move fast and
things the idea that it's desirable to
radically disrupt the existing order in
pursuit of something better and that's
really exciting stuff but we don't have
the luxury of taking that approach in
this industry we can't afford to have
our electric grid breakdown today on our
way to a more promising tomorrow we are
9% of the US economy and the other 91%
relies on us so we have to run a
business the supports and enables the
activities of all others the phrase I
use to remind my team of their
obligation to look at all the
implications of the transformational
steps we take and to be mindful of which
thread you're tugging on is technology
leads but policy rules while we often
think of regulation and policy is a
hurdle and it is it also embodies the
interconnected network of economic and
social expectations and so we have to be
mindful of that and this is where you
come in my message isn't simply that we
need to understand the system we're
dismantling although we do and it isn't
simply that we need to create the
correct new policies though we do it's
also that we need everyone at the table
this is once again where Pittsburgh got
it right where the city's vision mission
and Technology converged to bring this
20th century economic powerhouse into
the 21st century through a group of
critical stakeholders of which Carnegie
Mellon was first among equals it is also
where Carnegie Mellon is getting it
right bringing together different
schools engineering policy and business
to soak on this big question of energy
information energy transformation now we
must take the same approach in
reinventing and revel I revolutionising
the energy system across the United
States so I'm honored to be working with
all of you in forging the second
electric revolution it's important it's
exciting and I can't wait to see what
comes next
thank you very much for your time
[Applause]
we have questions that are coming in so
on your tables we've dropped a note
again about our app which is slide Oh
calm so we have a couple of questions
that have come in and so I have them
here on my iPad technology at work so if
you don't mind and sure thank you again
for a wonderful presentation Thanks I'll
be here the first question comes in from
Johanna and she wants to know what do
you see as their regulatory hurdles to
achieve your vision particularly with
micro grids yeah well there's many many
regulatory hurdles out there so one of
the challenges that we have is being
innovative and taking innovative steps
when you know the current regulatory
model you know really and the law really
sort of constrains what you can invest
in as an electric utility so for
instance the micro grid isn't precisely
within the four corners of the law in
terms of what were permitted to do
there's some questions about generation
ownership there's some questions we have
battery storage in there you know what
is the role of battery storage is at
generation is it distribution can the
utility own it we're a restructured
state so the question of generation
ownership is always there so it's you
know probably a twenty five million
dollar project at the end of the day and
the question is are you willing to place
that bet without knowing that you'll
actually recover those costs when you go
into the regulatory agency with your
rate case or do you want to sort of
carve a regulatory path to get some sort
of pre-approval that will very much slow
you down
so this micro grid we've been working on
for about three years
we made an attempt to set up legislation
that would allow us to build micro grids
that did work so we went to the
regulator and we actually got approval
for this just in February so you know
one of the hurdles
is how do you till ''tis engage in
innovative and experimental projects
when the law is not designed to
accommodate that and you're always doing
that at risk and I think you know we
understand that we're pushing the
envelope and there's a certain amount of
risk that we're willing to take but many
of these projects are going to be quite
expensive we just have a very expensive
business the infrastructure is not cheap
and so how much risk are you willing to
take is you know is always a question
and so that's one of the ways we've
tried to solve it we one of the things
we were able to do about a year ago at
the legislature was we took energy
efficiency and rather than write it
traditionally has been a pass-through
well basically if we spend a dollar on
energy efficiency we recover a dollar so
it's just a pass-through we turned it
into an earnings opportunity which in
cents you creates incentives in the
utility in our business it becomes a
part of our business so we're incentive
to want to do that the other thing we
did with energy efficiency to turn to
change it is we created a an RD bucket
around energy efficiency
now it's limited toward energy
efficiency but it is you know it is a
bucket of dollars that we have every
year to spend in innovation space but
it's specifically carved out in
legislation the next question we have is
how do you attract different industries
to create a unified vision for
collaboration and policy innovation what
is a shared motivation motivator well I
think the shared motivator first of all
it's not easy work and it's some of the
hardest work and I commend Carnegie
Mellon for what they're doing in terms
of bringing multiple disciplines within
the school together to focus on this and
honestly the Pittsburgh story is
phenomenal that doesn't happen every day
to bring various stakeholders together
you know create a common vision create a
roadmap accomplish the mission and
really drive something forward in that
way
so you know I think the con so it's hard
to do it takes a lot of work it takes
building trust over you know many years
amongst different people but I think you
know there has to be a shared vision of
the future and it's a shared vision that
creates broad benefits and that's how
you bring people and is that they see
benefits we're putting together a
collaboration right now around smart
cities in Chicago and there's academic
institutions there's Argonne National
Labs has developed a really you know a
neat kind of sensor that you can put out
it works on the system but it also has
environmental at you know sensing
aspects to it so we've got Argonne in
the mix there are the MacArthur
Foundation is in the mix and their focus
is very much around the human aspects of
what technology brings so I think you
you bring people together with a shared
vision that there are broad benefits and
when I look at energy transformation I
mean there is nothing I think you can
spend your time on this day today in
this current world that can have broader
impacts than energy transformation when
you think about environmental social
economic this is a business a system
that touches every aspect of our lives
quality of life and and to work on that
and ensure that the transformation
creates the broadest benefits I think is
really exciting so the next question is
is comment doing anything to work with
small and medium manufacturers to
improve their energy efficiency we are
we have some significant energy
efficiency programs for for businesses
in in our in our service territory and
you know when I talked about the energy
the energy efficiency trading platform
that we're trying that we're creating
it's in design phase so we got a lot of
work to do on it but we want to test
smart contracts and some of the
distributed ledger kind of concepts in
the business but the main focus of that
will be businesses you know because
they're going to have enough kilowatt
hour savings to make you know trading
impactful
and it will also be in their interest
that you know the goal here is to you
know you got to create some currency
around the kilowatt hour reduction in
order to trade them and the currency is
we know half of the fortune 500 more
than half of the fortune 500 companies
have sustainability goals and that's
what customers expect and that's what
investors expect I don't know if anybody
read the Blackrock letter to to you know
their their investment companies this
year but it was very much focused on
human benefits in the environment and
then that's what you know black rots
expecting from the companies that they
invest in but so the idea is to create
some currency but the focus will be on
on small and medium-sized businesses to
sort of create that trading platform so
yeah we're very we're very involved in
that next question and they're coming in
so we're going to give you a few more
good
what is comm Ed's roadmap to accommodate
the ever-increasing transportation
electrification yeah we are working on
that I would say we're you know there
are probably places and utilities around
the country that are a little bit ahead
of us on that I think California has a
lot going on with charging stations the
utilities in general have been very
focused on building charging stations
and the reason for that is the way we
make money is by building infrastructure
we put iron in the ground we go to the
regulator we pass it through a rate case
and we earn a return on it so anytime
you can put iron in the ground and your
utility it's a good thing I frankly
don't think that charging infrastructure
is where where the game is at on
electric transportation I think there's
so many more interesting questions in
you know the network aspects of it both
in terms of how does a person from
California who's driving across the
country and gets into your service
territory get charged and you know it's
almost like an ATM network how does that
work so I think that's a question that
we have to solve that's very interesting
and will require both competitive
companies and the you utility and then I
think the other really interesting
question around electric transportation
is when you've got when you're
managing a distribution grid and you've
got generation inside the distribution
grid and it's very volatile and you've
got people buying and selling and you're
really managing a much more dynamic grid
the questions of how you the contracts
that you create with vehicle owners how
you draw on their energy or ask them to
back off and pay them for demand
management all those questions of how
you manage the system in that in that
kind of scenario a lot of which will be
automated are are interesting questions
in my mind
we're working with environmental groups
in Illinois right now to to try to look
at electric transportation and think
about how we can jumpstart that for the
future but I think we're probably a
couple steps behind some other places on
that so a good question from a
university what kind of skills are you
looking for in your future employees
yeah that's a great question so we
definitely need technical skills
obviously there's a lot of Technology
here but we need people who can combine
that with you know sort of creative
thinking skills I mean you almost want a
little bit of Liberal Arts and a little
bit of Technology
you know blend it in I need people who
can be agile and nimble who can think
about you know playing a role on one
team one day and then you know a couple
months later shifting to another team
and playing a different kind of role and
so people who know how to be
collaborators and followers and leaders
when needed people who can be technical
but also can be you know creative and
see the you know human and you know
community side of things as well and the
impacts of their technology so it's
really interdisciplinary and again you
know I give you know Laurie and Carnegie
Mellon a lot of credit for you know
looking at this question
cross-functionally because that's the
way we're trying to solve it I'm
actually at a conversation with Laurie
earlier today about inside the company
yeah utilities are really really
hierarchical and they're very structured
very linearly so you have your
engineering lane and you have your
economists and you have your lawyers and
you have your finance people and they
haven't traditionally talked much to
each other
and so I'm throwing them all into the
same room and telling them that they got
to figure this out together and it's
very interesting it's very interesting
but I need people who can talk across
different functions and can kind of work
in those kind of teams because a team I
have together today in a couple months
it'll be a different team some of them
will be the same but I'll throw some new
people in there so this ability to kind
of shape-shift and morph and evolve
and you know play different roles is is
is is a big piece of what the future
will require I think in our companies we
always need good engineers with the law
limiting your business in some ways
how can startups engage with you are you
able to invest in innovative startups
yes oh I'll come at that question a
couple different ways one is so we're
part of a larger holding company exelon
exelon has five utilities and in a very
large generation company and so there's
exelon actually which has more of a
competitive side as well as a regulated
side actually does invest in in in
start-up companies so that usually that
comes through the exelon realm not so
much the regulated utility realm but
here's how I think we we think about
engaging with startups and third-party
companies I talked about the platform
model in the four layers that we've kind
of you know identified that we're trying
to work through and when I talked about
it I talked about the first layer being
really the infrastructure layer that's
kind of where we live today and that's
probably where I think the utility lives
for a long time in the future planning
and operating similarly I think you know
you probably want your utility to do
that when you get to layer 3 and you
start thinking about energy transactions
and you get to layer 4 and you start
thinking about
services transactions then I think you
start to bring in third parties because
that's not especially in a restructured
state like Illinois we run wires and
poles we don't run generation we're not
going to be involved in most of those
transactions it's going we're going to
facilitate them as a platform kind of an
ebay we connect buyers and sellers but
we're not the buyer or the seller for
the most part and so I think that's how
we think about bringing in the
innovation that small companies that
startups that new you know fresh views
of the industry can bring as well as
sort of maintaining the stability and
and doing what we do best
we have a marketplace right now it's
basically an internet marketplace but
it's a little bit of an experiment that
we're doing we've had enough of maybe a
year and a half now we've got smart
thermostats that we sell on it again
it's not we don't make smart thermostats
but nest does and others do ecobee and
so we sell those smart thermostats
across the marketplace we're evolving
the marketplace we expect to see solar
start to emerge in numbers probably
fourth quarter this year and we're
putting together a solar services
platform so if you're thinking about
purchasing solar you can come onto our
platform we'll pull down your usage
we'll take a google shot of your home
we'll give you the economics of running
solar off of your home if that's not
feasible we can give you the economics
of a share in a community solar program
and where you might find that similarly
once you make the investment in solar
we'll have a tracker that allows you to
track the economics the payback etc so
this is you know sort of the the
services platform again some of which I
think we can provide because we can do
that efficiently and some of which will
have third parties brought in and that's
how I think we'll connect at the utility
level the next question how can
universities help utilities the most to
advance innovation beyond research
well I we have I think you know part
partnerships and partnering in you know
very specific projects you know
obviously the research that comes out of
universities are tremendously helpful
and we you know rely on that quite a bit
and watch that I think that you know
coming in and being part of specific you
know projects and really helping to make
this work on the ground is I think sort
of a next phase of engagement where I
think there's lots of opportunity to
more questions is that okay sure okay as
long as you want to stay out so what
made you want to work in the utility
industry well we're getting personal um
so I practice an antitrust lawyer for
about 10 years and I got a call from a
headhunter about the time that the
restructuring law was passed in Illinois
late 90s and what the restructuring law
in Illinois did was was one of the first
states to restructure as they pulled
generation away from the transmission
and distribution network set him up
separately
ultimately separate subsidiaries and the
company was looking for lawyers who
understood markets because they didn't
have anybody or monopoly for a hundred
years they didn't have anybody really
internally who understood markets and
the legal entanglements of regulation
and you know when I got the headhunter
call I liked practicing antitrust law I
thought it was great
but I thought this is really the last
sort of fully economically regulated
industry obviously regulation hits most
industries in many different ways but
fully economically regulated industry
this was the last one to go through
restructuring you know Airlines had gone
telecommunications trucking and and and
you know you got you're sitting here
with the electric industry and you're
left with it and I thought it's just a
great opportunity you know for an
intellectual challenge and I never ever
thought I'd end up here I just thought I
was going to have a great time
practicing law in this
realm of untangling you know a
hundred-year network of regulation in a
way that would allow markets to work and
provide benefits you know to consumers
at the end of the day so that's why I
jumped alright so the last question what
is your strategy for handling the data
coming from new technologies and what
role do you see machine learning
techniques playing for tackling Grid
problems yeah I think so yeah data is a
is a huge question that is really you
know sort of underlies everything here
and there's a lot of work to be done
there so on the one hand we need data we
need to figure out how we use data for
operational purposes there is so much
opportunity to more be more efficient
operationally I mean we literally still
do you know our maintenance you know you
know time-based maintenance every couple
weeks we send somebody to the substation
to you know check the gases on the
transformer and you know to be able to
do condition based maintenance the the
amount of cost that will pull out of our
system is tremendous so that's you know
one lane of using data in in our
operations I think you know automation
and you know intelligence and robotics
also has you know tremendous benefits I
saw recently robotics that's used on we
use drones to fly our transmission lines
but I saw a robot that essentially you
know runs along transmission lines and
detects you know faults and when you
think about being able to do your
inspections and maintenance by virtue of
technology you know not only are you
going to run a better and more reliable
system but you're going to take cost out
so there's a big piece of data in
running our system that we have not
figured out we have just scratched the
surface and we need an awful lot of help
because it's just not our bailiwick
the second area
is the data that you need to animate
markets and there's always a push and
pull there there are you know third
parties who tend to want more of the
information than we want to give we're a
little concerned because obviously
security interests in this industry are
significant and and so we're very
careful about what kind of data gets out
there about you know system
configuration and that sort of thing so
there's a big push pull on that and I
think that will continue for some time
and you know we'll find the right
balance but we are cognizant of the fact
that we're going to have to share more
and that it's important to have it out
there in order to animate markets create
benefits for for consumers and then I'd
say the third bucket is really data
privacy and and you know maintaining
that and that is very parallel to what
we see in other commercial entities and
trying to make sure that we've got the
right practices as well as technology to
protect that but this is a huge area
it's an area where again it's not
particularly our you know our strong
suit and I think there's a lot of room
for for help on that okay thank you
I just want to take a moment to thank
him for all these her wonderful
insightful comments or breadth of
knowledge and her ability to translate
it and a way to get us off thinking
deeply was very notable and inspiring to
me so thank you very much in
[Applause]